my april wants to know
the mysteries chomsky pursues and feels
awestruck by
well i'm all struck by
for example the same things that galileo
was awestruck by
galileo and his contemporaries were
carrying out in the 17th century a
major revision of the whole
picture of science that's the birth of
modern science
questioning everything reconstructing it
and so on
and one of the topics that they were
interested in was
that struck there that captured their
attention was language
and they expressed galileo and others
expressed their
or awe and
amazement at um
an astonishing property of ordinary
language
somehow with a handful of
symbols a couple of dozen symbols we can
construct in our minds infinitely many
thoughts that be which is already
kind of miraculous how can this happen
and in addition
we can find a way to
convey these thoughts to the minds of
others
who have no access to our minds
now galileo regarded the alphabet as the
most stupendous of human inventions
the level of a michelangelo or titian
his contemporaries had the same view
i think they were right it's what i've
sometimes called the
galilean challenge how can this
miracle be achieved for descartes
this was essentially one of the basic
reasons why
he established mind as a
entity distinct from body because of the
way in which language is used creatively
to express an infinity of thoughts which
have never been heard before and
can somehow enable others who have no
access to our minds
enable them to nevertheless understand
let's see
grasp the workings of our minds that he
thought required
something outside the mechanical
universe
so that oh and amazement i think remains
we understand some parts of it not
others